yeah welcome to this video playing
hypnotic specter one of the more
frequent opponents and I got the request
to tell scores if they are substantial
or interesting verse 6 got six and a
half out of seven against the sky which
is really a lot considering his rating
but this is only with the chess
explained account i have played him
numerous times over the years with other
accounts and I'm I know that and I'm
also lost a number of games okay let's
see Kings Indian yeah the Kings Indian
let's go for a somewhat offbeat line
Bishop g5 this is quite often associated
with former world champion vasilis
Mislav it's an interesting line that
steers the game into own rather
strategical kind of water be 392 it it
is a bit only wear white does not play
you for early to avoid giving black
young points of attack maybe I should
have played yeah okay it's not another
problem he's got g5 night h5 winning the
bishop at the bishop power let's say I
was just briefly thinking sometimes you
can avoid that with clever move orders
but it's not the end of the world oops
came not think too much with b5 is
really playing slowly and I know what
I'm talking about I'm playing slowly
myself ok 9 a-5 yeah this threatened 94
so 92 is very often the standard
reaction to that it also
etsy form and may go to see form if
black transposes to a kind of modern
benoni set up with e6 and taking on d5
this doesn't really fit to what he
played before while we fibers also on we
had moved Wow still nerdy fitted with
Queen a five to be honest okay let's
just complete development also it's
interesting or important that i did not
castle yet this gives white some
additional ideas the main one being to
play G form and I'll do that this is an
interesting interesting setup not
castling into gaining space on the Kings
side
his only source for counter plays at
five anyway and this is what I'm trying
to prevent okay while g5 is not good too
right no it's not a good move but I can
play h4 h5 let's prevent that and sorry
prepare that and Bishop on g3 also takes
a look at the d6 pawn which is important
because II phone might be a way for him
to activate the bishop so if he goes
before I can just capture d6 yeah he
goes for it anyway I was just about to
mention that you could try to make this
work as a pawn sec with 95 it's probably
not objectively enough but interesting
yeah okay bye and I must take it no no
way I'm not going to take all right so
this is interesting 93 yeah edgy form
the question is I can play Knight B 3
here and win even more material very
greedy stuff taking on c5
yeah not sure I want to do that
okay let's just do that it's not clear
to me what is next moves you can play 93
yeah but now i take c 5 can i cannot
take it it's lots of material already
two points to central pawns and they
have bishop deform this is a very nice
square for the bishop yeah still
probably at some point he will get some
play against my king this is the
position would be just outright winning
if I hadn't played G form of course this
is a cannot say it's not possible to to
get to this position without having g4
played what no this is the Gasol's of
counter play my week my week am King
okay yeah he can play jack III now the
same check but I'm not sure that this
really am helps him the d3 porn is also
very weak
the idea is simply Queen f3 and take it
and you know what the Queen B 6 i'm just
about to mention this is the the thing
that I could this code term could be an
idea but let's um let's see if I go see
five here we can take be two can play
Knight f3 to to Kevin yeah might be
three hmm yeah this Queen B form but i
can i can just apply can play c5 yeah
and the position is slightly slightly
uncoordinated and this um this might
might be a problem ok this is this is
sir but this is helping right i can just
take him queen before i ever care for
we're grateful then you need to go back
all the way
yum
yeah I understand he needs to ROP three
oh no don't tell me this is working
rookie three ah come on this is check
from a completely winning position I get
into this crap no more come on yeah even
this is good no come on can i play kinky
too maybe
rookie three i think was just outright
winning maybe this mary had naija fall
he just hits check and go 94 again I
this is nite nite be to not be to
winning the Queen not so I need to go
here check stone 122 a second check
check y'all know I'm winning again
time warning
I will be fine check check check check
check white market yeah cuz pre-move
nonsense yeah I just hate this at the
end it's just what what is there's no
relation to chess anymore I get may I
could have played nonsensical moves
earlier and one on time but I try to
play at least and a decent ones yeah
yeah I just bet I mean the whole game
was been completely completely gone this
game for black and then he didn't take
any of his chances yeah before instance
queen of three years just just dead and
I'm I'm up what the peace couple of
bones I don't know enough and he Rookie
three years of course much stronger yeah
check please check willing all kinds of
stuff it doesn't seem to win though
strangely enough yeah but still like you
should do that this shackle it's also
playable okay I'm down on on on 30
seconds check very hard to to do
anything check Getty I'm just winning
you can play 93 again and but I simply
we went in to promote far too too late
thinking about stuff like that when she
didn't see at all check yeah well okay
now you see how to how to lose again
against the sky had didn't tell you one
before you can overstep the time in a
completely winning position yeah yeah
well it's a it's an old story why did by
doubt they have a simple one second
incremented you can you can avoid those
nonsensical end of games check but it
doesn't dumb it doesn't help alright
thanks for watching